did you do anything for
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving yeah you Paige
came to visit you right from
Alabama yeah she cooked you guys dinner
yeah she did yeah that was nice I know
she come surpris me she surprised you
yeah oh what a what a nice surprise L
need something about but I did oh yeah
she PR away it's so nice to you made a
great friend like
that she told Larry huh she told Larry
well she has to tell somebody just to
coordinate it and then she surprised
dddy a that's your best
friend she drives from Alabama to see
you
wow
bless
you I'll buy you a new
jacket there you
go have Ray and Timmy ever been to this
Cemetery have Ray and Ray and Timmy ever
been to Family Cemetery yeah yeah he's
been yeah
yeah yeah
they they
Freddy oh yeah for
Freddy team being
EP
yeah
oh
Bow
any
[Music]
come that little dirt road right
there s us right yeah you be right
here I remember
that
yeah I me I me the old house right there
yeah made it
Y
Man
[Music]
[Applause]
L
back
hey
Timmy I here
baby come
on
bu
[Music]
that's Grandpa Papa that's grandma right
there mama
mama
me
[Music]
it yeah
by born
1944 how how
sister
brother yeah in the ground
ready
[Music]
got
turn
backs they got 1940 back they got 1940
right
here
1944 194
bar
[Applause]
that's your
sister
Barber
ready
so you had two younger siblings you have
two younger siblings that passed away
the two youngest how how did they
die how how did they pass away he had a
m heart attack yeah young age like 40
years old yeah 40 years young
wow our younger sister still
away and Michael was more like Ray and
ready or more like you and and Barbara
like
yeah but he died
early
yeah it's a beautiful spot for a
cemetery we got a lot of be here know
all
of I tell Mark we got all kind of P of
beer right
here yeah they hit house right there
they
that the
house this is this is your whole family
right here huh this is your whole family
right here yeah my grandpa up there was
that
right
my dad oh that's your grandfather I
can't hey Henry that's your dad's dad
yeah dad's dad
[Music]
Papa great great grandpa
huh great great grandpa you're great
great grandpa jimy
got old my old brother
[Music]
s
come they di before we were oh was that
right they when they that oh and they
were babies still boy they call yeah
right
right I remember my mom
tell
[Music]
daddy and mommy beard down
there right
there
be I didn't
that
[Music]
here I don't
know bother
with I get this Mom and
[Music]
Daddy
yeah there all kind
l
oh something here I don't
know right
here
D
DAV David
Whitaker born in
Mary
whiter come here I don't I don't know
Mark I
don't
[Music]
Mom
[Applause]
[Music]
Dad JT
wher 1872
hey I didn't know spelled differently
the last name is spelled differently on
that last
one yeah
one I I made that same mistake in the
first video yeah I thought it was one
te
who down there there's a bunch more
Whitakers here huh there's a bunch more
Whitakers
here
William wh William
whar you remember any of these people
are
Larry are you
Larry I him here hey
back hey
[Applause]
back
oh wow
BBY
right what do you what do you think of
all this Betty what do you think of
seeing your sister and seeing Barbara
and Freddy and all these your parents
what do you think of of
the
[Music]
hey on
your r
you feed on yourself
[Applause]
right some of these are just unmarked I
knowbody
Mar
got
died in
[Music]
1982 year mommy died in
daddy two
years
Y a't in
1997 Mama y ain't in
Barber D
[Music]
late
200 hey
right you look
at 2 one
20238 years just F now I'm looking at
that man look at
this8 yeah oh that's 8 years yeah 8
years3
two
two 8
[Music]
9 do you remember some of these people
you do
who's
[Music]
this who's
Eileen is that your sister
yeah I remember Barbara huh I remember
Barbara you me Barbara I remember Freddy
and Barbara
yeah
Michael he he didn't made Michael died
right before I met you guys yeah
the
B
go no it's cold it gets cold here yeah
lorine was
freezing lorine went back in the car
yeah yeah
FL
[Music]
yeah what that did you know this the
yeah I figured about this
man
again don't pee on your
[Music]
Ro yeah he that
go it's too cold to whip it
out I
know there go
again
R you're peeing on your sister's
Gra
[Music]
oh hold right there right
come come
on you hit that hole D you you don't you
don't want to fall in these holes you
might not get out
no you know what can't even make a time
like that put it down the road down here
with B up yeah it's hard to find yeah
it's hard to
find he what they say put one down hill
wh cemeter That's ceter yeah should be
called Whitaker Cemetery huh should be
called Whit should be called Whitaker
Cemetery it's all it's all full of
Whitakers there's not a single Garden in
there
[Music]
yeah
get in I got
get
yep that very
okay
okay let's strap on the Feed
Bag
[Applause]
[Music]
wait ray ray ray wa no
you go out that
door
you can to leave it down Kenneth cuz
you're going to be getting back
[Applause]
[Music]
in
gentle you're a gentleman Lauren oh me
okay how are you going to order Kenneth
you want to order for everybody huh you
want to order for everybody I don't know
what everybody want what do you think
they
want where you
comeon you want a
Whopper yeah give me a Whopper Whopper
yeah
hamburger we
got I can just get a bunch of Whoppers
fries and drinks yeah it'll be okay
Whoppers and Fries drink what we got one
two 3 four five
six I go you bunch of food we'll we'll
figure I'll get you a bunch of food and
we'll figure it
out all right I'll take
care put
on who's the
king put on
right hey turn to run back
hey hey oh come on he doesn't want it he
doesn't want it you got you got to
respect when Ray doesn't want something
he does not want
[Music]
it
got Burger King he
[Music]
hey
hy you can put it right
there
than you're sweet thank
[Music]
you
help
[Music]
yourself give you
one
wff I
here
right
good
they'll bring
him would you like me to sit oh just any
put them on top of that tray
maybe you actually will take this try
and you just put it right on top of
that thank you Don you're
welcome take it down
Dy
welome
is it
good is it
good oh oh look
out the ketchup will squirt all over the
place
one time
than
is with the music H is it
okay no it's
[Music]
okay you're
welcome hi
that
[Music]
bad
look
[Music]
is it good
Lorraine
I'm a huge fan Ray is so glad to meet
you
man
yeah
yeah yeah yeah I heard ra here and I was
like oh my God I'm on my way
yeah cuz I'm a huge fan every I'm always
watching y'all I'm always watching y'all
huge fan huge
fan y'all have people that love
y'all y'all way I'm so proud of you huh
I'm so proud of you for doing the cross
word
puzzles I'm always watching you doing
that I'm so proud of you you came a long
ways you came a long way what's your
name my name is Billy right Billy yeah
I'm a huge
fan yeah my
wife works here oh cool yeah maybe she
brought out the food for us yeah
maybe yeah long little shorter one yeah
she brought the yeah that's my wife
she's so glad to meet you
R
yeah this is my wife this is Jennifer
hey Jennifer yeah thanks for helping us
out this is Jennifer we're always
watching
y'all know
it I've been we've been praying for
y'all you
know y
always
yeah man
y I might take her home well come
on
brother
I I need
one it's all right don't worry about
that we get this we'll get this you're
all
right we want to thank y'all so much Ray
buddy you came along the way man
I just want to thank you so working on
them cross wordss man all that's good
stuff Ray good meeting you
man good meeting you
Ray bye line bye
[Music]
bety
cute
no you're
Queen are you
ready hey hey hey hey hey we waiting for
Larry
m
how you good how are you
good going to a cemetery is always
interesting isn't it huh going to your
family's
Cemetery or going to see a a gravite of
somebody that you loved is always
[Music]
interesting let you
see
that
I love a
v
where yeah right H where
yeah I'm my home h
yeah
okay
what now here I got you on the road
ready there you go what way you
going